[Applause]
[Music]
hey
welcome back to the break room
our daily uh nerdy news show keeps you
up to date on everything you need to
know um shout out bill's mafia
congratulations on your win no if tommy
back told sounds a little haggard today
it's because he is a lot of haggard
today he was at the thursday night
football game last night
um
let me tell you something brother
i went to hell and back last night and
by last night i mean 10 a.m when i
poured my first whiskey and dr pepper oh
god culminating in my whole body
cramping at midnight letting me know
nature's way of saying you'll die if you
do this again yeah
but in the end it was worth it
dominated i hate i hate our chat
help tommy's gucci get moochie thank you
uh one second i'll describe what what
those super chats god slow down on the
money because there is a bad incentive
listen uh let me go ahead and say it we
got a lot of cool stuff for today's show
but tommy's holding it right now we do
have a pocky one chip challenge okay
we've been teasing this nasty freak all
week
tommy himself mr t michael bechtold has
committed too if we hit 600 bucks in
super chats today he will eat that i
heard a different figure i like that
zack's already born again
that was the number right 6.50 650.
but i do want to say this if we hit 400
dollars tommy will eat the one chip
that's not true
wait isn't this the one chip for 400
i'll crinkle the one chip in my hand and
kamehameha
uh no uh listen tomorrow's my first day
at d23 and i'm going into the marvel
star wars panel don't make me go in with
a
with both holes on fire no you know keep
your cash in your pockets and trash bags
yeah guess what trash keep the cash this
week yes yeah please
i know all you poor people don't have
enough to give your friday shekels
anyway there's no chance of donating
you're all miserable disney plus is like
a buck 99 now and you're like i don't
know if i can swing this
i ain't eating this chip you don't have
the balls to donate 650 bucks i've also
said now again this is an even worse
idea and i'm uh already regretting that
i'm about to say it if we hit 700
tommy and i
will
lady in the trampoline okay
then starting at the end okay we gotta
make this happen and we will meet in the
middle both of us suffering the
repercussions by the way hi mom i'm glad
you're watching my mom's watching too uh
okay other stuff though that's not the
only thing that will be happening how
about two dogs kissing in the chat
and that is no matter when we if we hit
that threshold this will be happening at
the end of the episode because it will
ruin whatever comes after that yeah but
i think we'll give it like 10 minutes so
they can watch us frolick we're not
gonna do it at like 359 or 550.
uh on today's episode we got more d23 uh
stuff we're going to be talking about
before we send tommy on his merry way
down there to anaheim to be there in
person uh she hulk heads back to the
courtroom
and maybe we see the softer side of zeus
hey
it's friday and i'm thrilled to be here
my name is zach carlson with me here
i've got john costa always gusty to
mussy hey hey oh we've got john
michelson how's it going folks hey oh
heyo hey yo and tommybacktalk what's up
my children
tom de maximoff is here today delivering
the good word of the bill's mafia i
don't like that your uh lower third
camera has you in a single now yeah
aren't you the director of this show
john
don't you get your set up
you're probably getting ready for this
ship if that happens if you guys want to
hear thomas voice get even worse we're
giving the people
uh a couple more nuances to the
redemption oh a lot of good puppy kiss
emojis in the chat thank you kiss emojis
a couple more nuances to the redemption
right uh
please send in your d23
hottest takes in those super chats uh
we're gonna be reading a bunch of them
and then we're gonna pick our favorite
we're gonna pick our favorite at the end
of the show uh crown you the winner yeah
so send those super chats in also
very important tommy and
zach yeah are in a battle
a mug battle and i want to thank all my
mug thugs who have been out there
repping this mandatory fund having some
mandatory son i get it it's hard for you
guys most of you are making 40 50 bucks
a week collecting bottles and cans out
of your houses okay
and i appreciate that you strung a few
together to your mandatory fun mug
now quite frankly it's not enough not
enough of you have bought it and like i
said i got the addresses i got the names
i will be making house calls for anyone
that buys a morbid time mug and i'll
also be making sensual house calls for
the mandatory [ __ ] my god
john was starting to say we currently
for sale on new rockstarsmerch.com there
are two mugs okay one designed by tommy
it says mandatory fun and some lame ass
graphics the other designed by myself it
says it's morbid time okay and has a
clock okay
i forget what you said at the last mug
meeting you thought eugenics was a
pretty good idea yeah i did not no oh
you didn't say that i just had the mug
mug sales support eugenics nicholas
johnson in the chat saying zaddy's mug
is best mug i'm gonna buy a whole case
my man
we reset the counter to zero at the
start of this episode and uh we've got a
goal behind us and we're gonna check in
throughout the course of the show here's
the thing what's the name of that white
nationalist that got punched richard
richard spencer
bunch of a bunch of men
jordan
thinks that these bugs are not evolved
to their faults stop
uh um if hey look which is why he bought
those ones that's right every time
peterson loves the man
every time i'm on a friday show i try to
do something stupid and unhappy if one
of these mugs hits 120 sales on newrax's
merchant.com i will pull the chat i will
drink i will fill the winning mug full
of
whatever you choose mustard uh and and
drink the whole thing on camera i hope
you while they're eating in pockets oh
my god i just want to just real quick
we're about to we're about to hit the
headlines but i just want to point out
we were all legal adults yes
okay uh technically we're all employed
um we pay taxes uh we have driver's
license yeah and we are debasing
ourselves in various ways for your
entertainment
now the headline hey
bray girl bought both bucks guys feel
free to buy both mugs
i say buy you know i buy three you get
both of them in the mail and then you
think it's a vote i think it was brandon
that pointed out yesterday if you buy
the losing mug because again the winning
mug will become the permanent official
mug of the break room will stay on sale
the losing mug becomes a collector's
item
voting ends at midnight on sunday you
only have a limited time to do this oh
that's right one of these books has gone
away forever and i know that if i miss
out on an opportunity to buy an it's
morbid time mug i would never forget
that's right and by the way
it's uh we forgot to announce the
official tagline of the it's morbid time
mug is they're great for pissing it
oh if that's your if that's your
favorite people buy it
did we already do the headlines graphic
play that nasty boy again yes
speaking of piss um okay wonderful we
got some good headlines coming in today
uh susan sarandon confirmed that parts
of the new blue beetle movie will be in
spanish with subtitles english subtitles
presumably that's cool susan serranoon
is in this film right she's not just
reporting on that
she's in her career
she's had to turn to the reporter
just curiously walking by set the other
day and the actress was thinking and
espanol maybe maybe she gets some
contract work to do closed captioning
that's uh that's one of the things that
i liked
about west side story was they just did
a lot of spanish and they didn't even
subtitle it
if you're if you're a fan of the recent
hulu hit prey
right the whole thing was in uh
comanche right like no english really
spoken
to in french were the two languages
in that movie brad brad i see you man
you've been super chatting every day
this week comic con merch we're dealing
with it i had to go out of town a lot i
got a little bit distracted everybody
that signed up for their merch that we
selected will be getting their merch in
the next couple of weeks bear with me i
always said there's a 36 week
turnaround and there are no refunds
because you did not pay a dime that's
right okay but thank you for reminding
us in the chat oh we got a new trailer
uh this is a pretty nice trailer a lot
of new footage in this for black adam uh
dropped including you know a little
amanda waller saying who's on the team
uh kind of hinting at her previous uh
appearances in suicide squad films did
she die
she got no she got knocked out
she guided
arrow in the air over here
or in the green lantern verse too right
didn't she die in that too is that how
me is not well having watched the
peacemaker is she in that show she is
she is
both her and a character playing her
daughter spoiler alert for a movie or a
show that came out six months ago
trailer looks great i will say the vfx
are pretty sick kind of sets up what we
had anticipated was the general plot of
like the justice society
you know confronting black adam we
presume maybe recruiting him by the end
but um we're having a little technical
difficulties here dash was grabbing uh
um you know uh
just assume that he treats his mugs like
he treats his av equipment okay and
it'll be faulty
if you buy that mug you won't be able to
be heard by your family members just
remember
this mug is odorless so if you need a
little
in your coffee in the morning what all
mugs are odorless get out of here um
okay ooh in star wars news hollywood
reporter has announced that uh ahsoka
has cast
i and i'm going to butcher another name
here apologies to this person iman
asfandi
as ezra bridger i believe we have an
ezra yes uh
better than ezra
for sure
um well and i think i caught that uh i
think did i see this only this is the
gentleman who played the live action
aladdin oh really i was gonna say that a
lot of people were fantastic in this so
it's really cool to see that i think i
saw that apologies i i am i might be
confusing the answer i'm pretty sure
that's him yeah um oh via artist jeremy
love on instagram we got another look at
concept art for eternity from thor love
and thunder um
oh there it is
wow uh yeah it's similar to kind of what
we had but eternity has like a house now
yeah it's like a temple as opposed to
just that water area that yeah you know
it's funny because in the the final
product was kind of reminded me of the
soul stone world end game and so i
wonder if there was they did that on
purpose to try to tie those things
together maybe or yeah maybe this
concept art was like them trying to
differentiate a little bit more and
they're like actually now it's cool if
they look very similar yeah right yeah
the end result was great and and
certainly the actual character design
very similar to what we got yeah it's
the exact same very kind of comics
accurate yeah can't uh can't put that
big structure in a best buy parking lot
which is where they shot that's that's
right that's right they really yeah yeah
that's what natalie portman said yeah
wow wow everyone's got busy in a burger
king bathroom hey
okay that's from the song shout out to
everybody that's down with digital
underground um oh speaking of thor 11
thunder we got a new deleted scene um
that has some marvel fans upset
let's take a look at this deleted scene
i want to teach you something
something i haven't even told my sons
i have a lot of sense
thunderbolt
can be anything
thunderbolt
it's just electricity you can have it
anytime you call power is everywhere you
just have to harness it
now you point
yeah i think like people were sort of
like why didn't we get a little bit more
of this kind of energy of like
you know a little bit more sentimental a
little bit more it seems like zeus was
originally gonna be like a mentor
character yeah we saw that other deleted
team where he was in the hospital and
jane and thor
and then they sort of just played him
off for jokes and ended up killing him i
think people were sort of like the upset
is maybe like a little bit of a
clickbait way to phrase that headline
but people are sort of like oh i wish we
had more tender moments yeah like that
in that movie i think that goes a long
way of explaining how he can
you know imbue the power of zeus into
all the objects that the kids have at
the end so that's actually a twofer to
make the movie seem a little more
grounded and serious but also to explain
a little bit more of that part of the
ending yeah yeah um yeah well who knows
i mean yeah there's clearly a very
different film and a very different zeus
we could have gotten yeah maybe i wonder
too how much of the zeus we did get was
because they needed him to kind of be a
joke bad guy to set up the hercules
now you be my champion kind of an angle
i i don't know um okay uh speaking of
which yeah i think uh tommy mentioned it
in his earlier insults of the audience
um
you know disney plus is 199 right now if
you've never signed up for disney plus
before and thor 11 thunder is streaming
on disney plus right so like 1.99 is
half a paycheck for a lot of these
things
yeah presumably i would get i would
guess
98.99 of our audience already subscribes
to disney plus and maybe the people that
don't are borrowing a lot or live in a
country that doesn't yet have disney
plaza or that one french guy that hacked
into my account and kept changing my
simpsons episodes to french with chinese
subtitles oh that's how do you know it
wasn't a chinese person no
oh my gosh okay um
uh so anyways that's just a little uh
we're not being paid to plug disney plus
but there's a lot of good content on
there you can catch up with she-hulk and
you can watch for 1100 it's cheaper than
a vod purchase just subscribe to disney
plus maybe check out some old episodes
of sunny with a chance and get your boy
some residuals
i like we pulled the chat if if they
were upset about that scene included 67
said yes
yeah it's a good thing hell yeah yeah
but also could we pull the chat and also
be like would you prefer to have had
every deleted scene back into the movie
would you rather throw 11 thunder have
been six hours long um a lot of people
would say yes because we just want more
of the things we like right um according
to
uh thor levin thunder assembled
documentary that's also currently on
disney plus natalie portman has big
concerns about ruining continuity in the
film
uh said her co-star chris hemsworth
portman was kind of you know this was a
very different direction for the
character and i think had some real
concerns about hang on does this match
the continuity from this and that and we
just said that doesn't matter
portman's the only one who cares about
canon okay i love why tt and hemsworth
just slashing and hacking so i i love
the new like go-to
press like marvel
talent outward like disdain for marvel
like continuity and like meaning and
they're like yeah basically our approach
every time we make a movie is to be like
what if feige lost his mind over how bad
this was
let's
let's let's ignite the incels a little
harder with our quotes
um which i do love and like you know a
quick reminder natalie portman started
out as a child actor she went to yale
okay she's a smart cookie she's uh
you're at clown classes full you're a
clown class yeah
doing clown work with yahoo
yeah okay did she uh did she do like red
nose do you think or was she more of
like one of those big shirts
i don't think she's gonna do that isn't
it [ __ ]
no natalie apartment went to harvard
harvard not yale
clown school for
natalie come on to show you [ __ ]
chrissy tell us in the chat where did
where did natalie portman go to college
i went to three colleges also i mean
there's a long history of famous child
actors going to really fancy schools i
believe claire danes also went to like
one of those ivy leagues i want to see
those sct scores okay are they getting
in on merit or because they're famous
and have had movies and tv shows jerry
seinfeld went to suny oswego
that's where i went so me and seinfeld
equals wow
um oh we have a new uh she-hulk kind of
second half of the season trailer love
it
i think we're gonna play it now
i'm still jennifer walters she-hulk is
just a thing that happened to me you
said you didn't like the name she helped
i don't i do admit though there are
parts of it that i enjoy
the amazing hair
no hangover
being able to walk home at night without
being afraid
you put on your green suit put on my
green tip yeah jolly green yourself i
don't know what you call it hulking out
okay good whatever
trouble's gonna find you
weird unexpected
[Music]
i'll be right back
life would be so much easier if i was
just jen i think you're in a unique
position to do some real good jen
walters can use the law to help people
when society fails she-hulk can help
people when the law fails
this guy's really kind of doing it for
me
[Music]
you're getting it energy we've seen a
lot of those clips before but there's
definitely a lot of footage including
the kind of the classic iconic purple
white outfit uh bicycle shorts on jen
obviously a lot of daredevil footage in
there a lot more titania some more
abomination what else are we thinking
from that trailer
i mean i mean it's just we we that's our
first look at matt yeah we've only seen
daredevil up into this point it looks
like they're in legal eagle or whatever
the bar the lawyer borrows yeah
um i i just i mean
that line is really good right like uh
you know jennifer can help people that
society has failed and and she'll can
help people that the law has failed it's
just like yeah that's probably it's
probably matt sumatra in general anyway
yeah yeah i think green arrow can tell
people that the city has failed exactly
right now i failed this is a different
universe tommy we need portman in here
to correct that bro where the hell is
portman come on the show you coward
face me dick cavett natalie come on the
show we'll talk about any of your films
all the beautiful girls uh
fox lux vox love
to talk fox whatever you want to talk
professional uh yeah leon the
professional
featuring gary oldman oh
wow gary oldman
uh wait a second what was the one she
did with uh the hotel chevrolet or
whatever that was like the west anderson
short closer oh yes which is naked in
that oh yeah
i didn't know that i forgot about that
one i mean cover it up but still
tasteful nude i think um yeah come on
the show natalie it was awesome
[Laughter]
but yeah that's a pretty fun trailer
again a nice mix of stuff we haven't
seen stuff we have seen
uh jolly green giant yourself is a fun
way to refer the whole king out
excellent i just want to say for the
record
for our new rockstars poll about what we
think is going to happen i have put matt
in uh she-hulk
hooking up
i just want to say for the record i
think i might be getting some points
on that trailer are you saying
matt murdock and she all cook up are you
saying matt murdock and jennifer walters
hook up i forget what was the exact
question but i
even before the trailer i was thinking
it could be both or either because it
could be kind of like a bat woman i mean
bat batman catwoman situation batman
returns where they they like each other
and they like their alter egos well i
think it's also clearly the most recent
episode of she-hulk set up that like she
can find uh a romantic relationship but
so far only as she-hulk yeah as jennifer
she struggles right maybe he as a lawyer
yes who and also understands the dual
identity part of it is the first person
who can kind of connect to her on that
level that's what i'm saying
about that
very attractive person
the show is setting up the fact that
like she can't get a date as as jennifer
but she can't get a date maybe that's a
uh question
would their ship name be she devil oh
that would be jerome
shout out meryl streep and uh
roseanne
um
don't shout out also
rosanna proud owner of six mormon
champions no no wait speaking of which i
want to do a quick mug check oh mug
check i see it okay here we go morbid
time mug 37 sales whoa mandatory fun mug
forty-five six oh
no no no no no fill this in while you do
the next one you don't understand you're
gonna miss a chance to have morbid time
all the time
i'm telling you this mandatory mug fund
doesn't a man toy fun mug doesn't win i
leave the show forever no
that's not true
not true don't don't don't falsely be
hard to have more you want mandatory fun
you buy the mug you don't buy the mug
mandatory fun becomes push-up contest
every day and i'm not participating i'm
judging
bad content film juice get out of the
chat we don't want you here
talk to him come on
oh speaking of she-hulk ginger gonzaga
who plays nikki on the show gave an
interview to tv line where she said
yes that hot legal action with pens and
highlighters that you've all been asking
for the show is now definitely switching
into what it looks like when you have
pretty idiot super villains and
superheroes who are either antagonizing
you or need to be represented by you
kind of hinting at we're going to see
more courtroom stuff going on in the
second half of the show we haven't spent
a ton of time in the courtroom as of now
that's one of the things i didn't like
about um oh i missed and daredevil the
series is like we you know we i wanted
to see him being a lawyer more we only
had i think that one case where he
represented that guy that kingpin
actually set up for but yeah i think it
would be a miss opportunity to not have
more legal part of the legal show yeah
also i want a special thanks uh everyone
is buying both mugs i think that's
really nice of you because one obviously
you're gonna have to you're gonna you
can use zach's mug as a pedestal to put
my mug on top of it
so everybody can also um tag new
rockstars through the break room on on
twitter instagram whenever you receive
your your mug shipments yeah show us
maybe we'll do a carousel or something
like that in the show and and show off
or i was telling john will will uh
gladly rep everybody that tags us with a
picture of them in their mug and one
person who does it we will choose them
to roast yeah we will furiously roast
it's a mug roast just not you personally
but just like everything else that's in
the photo your your kitchen decoration
the lighting uh anything like that and
i'll be honest i know a lot of you don't
have kitchens so
just uh whatever hallway you're
squatting in right now go under a like
whatever trunk and whatever car you're
sleeping in whatever whatever uh circus
tent
you in the traveling circus job where
you shovel elephant [ __ ] i i gotta say
uh tom just mentioned it but if you're
living that van life or hatchback life
or station wagon life or minivan life or
whatever if you're living in your car
right now you know what makes for a good
soup receptacle you can eat beans out of
this you can uh brush your teeth out of
this oh yeah there's a lot of stuff more
intense and also if you are living there
and you're dealing with you know
possibly
you know transients at night that might
come and attack you the mormon mugs are
so fragile and poorly built you can
shatter them and turn them into
something established whereas the
mandatory fund mugs are impossible to
break
but also
stealth mode at night actually it was
very important to protect there's some
neon embellishments though that i think
would make you an easy target whereas
this is so confusing now
the big topic of the entire week right
is d23 coming up tomorrow tommy's going
to be heading down there him brandon
barrack we're going to meet up with eric
voss who's already in anaheim
um and they are going to attend
the big awesome uh panel yeah that is
going to have announcements for 20th
century 20th
20th century films no longer a fox in
there uh
lucasfilm yep and of course marvel okay
feige confirmed to be in the building
coy claims that he's going to be in
anaheim for under an hour or whatever
that is he's keeping the jet running
which where does he lives in l.a right
taylor swift yeah him and him
but i think it's taylor's doo-doo
hey you know what she should learn how
to shake it off okay
um uh okay but uh when i'm off the plane
there's nothing in my brain don't don't
cover up swifties don't come we know you
are the most um weaponized fan base in
the world please don't come through
because the play
kind of the open to the public uh
non-panel part of the convention that's
already taking place eric was sharing
some fun photos that he's taking down
there right now um they're playing some
kind of sizzle reels
in the hall uh for folks including a
marvel one that had a little bit of
footage and some it's a lot of stuff
we've already seen or stuff from
previous films they're kind of
repackaging but there's footage from
echo footage from the marvels nice um
and then a big segment on x-men 97.
there was also a different clip that
showed footage from black panther
wakanda forever ant-man of the wasp
quantomania and
i don't know if i saw secret innovation
no it was mixed so the tricky thing was
it was mixed with some stuff we had
already seen some stuff from panel and
then like some slit just some baby
little new shots here and there and and
we could presume that like that is a
sizzle for a lot of what we're going to
see tomorrow flesh down right like
probably that that 17 seconds on x-men
97 will become a 15-minute presentation
unfortunately
people are gonna have to wait till
monday to hear from us right that's not
true tom oh it isn't that's not true we
will be reporting live from this studio
during the panel and then tommy and
brandon are going to call in as soon as
they're done watching because they're
going to see a lot of footage that won't
be released to the public right they're
going to they're going to tell us a heat
meter on what the audience was
responding to
23 and you see me and brandon holding
phones up to our faces come over and
join the show yeah
we're gonna be looking for fans to chat
with yeah yeah we want to talk to the
people the disgusting unwashed people
so don't get too close to me or i will
put my nose plugs on and shun you oh my
god
by the way kudos to you um also we got
some new logos for two projects that
have previously been confirmed daredevil
born again in captain america new world
order there they are oh wow
which one that's the deal
finally getting the dd similar to what
we saw but a little dd oh and there's
captain america a new world order i like
this because it kind of includes the
falcon yeah symbology right with sam
wilson being kept now so is there
anything about secret invasion or no
they're being weirdly tight-lipped about
that even though the armor wars nothing
on that or iron heart well yeah armor
wears who knows but like
it does feel because the long-running
rumor is we're going to get a trailer
for secret invasion that is the next
disney plus series that's starting
spring 2023 yes maybe april march we
don't know um
but like presumably we would get that
before the end of this current disney
plus series she-hulk but there's been
nothing besides casting there's been
nothing about that series
no you know i don't i don't know some
some people were saying they might just
fold it into a different series
secretion or iron that was just like
speculation that you know was just here
and he was saying that they at least
they had a trailer at comic-con as we
know but we didn't the public didn't get
to see it
sorry secret invasion oh yeah sorry
did you talk about armor warriors that
might get it for secretary oh okay oh
john's got his finger on the pulse he
says we're getting a trailer for secret
invasion tomorrow and again we'll be
here live reacting to it uh also eric
vos who will be at that same panel right
with his photographic eyeballs we'll be
taking everything in and we'll be doing
uh separate reaction videos and
breakdowns as soon as his um
uh energy depleted body will allow him
to well we got him some non-sponsored
ag-1 to fire him up but i also heard
that he was mixing it in his mandatory
fun mug that he said was the only one
you'll ever drink these are the only
four of the these are all prototypes
these are the only things i think i'm
saying i can't stop pissing in my
marbling time mug it's so fun to piss
hey you know what if if you need if you
need a mobile toilet i'm not against you
buying a morphing time one
i don't care what you use it for just
buy one
if you like it you like it that's right
people don't leave no no king shaming on
this show the mandatory fun goes down
the router
the marvin time hangs out by the tudor
film juice get out of here who left film
juicing i said film juice yeah i said we
don't want you here um okay but i buy
your book
jessie waller this is a good good good
good
good
good
good
good
good
good
good good
good
good
good
good
good
good
good good
good
good
good
good
good
good
good good
good
good
good
good
good
good
good good
good
good
good
good
good
jesse was asking what time the stream is
tomorrow so the panel starts at 10 a.m
we're all gonna probably be in the
office ready to go live around 10 a.m
but we're gonna just you know we're not
going to go live until good stuff is
going to force you to sit through a
bunch of crap
if there's 45 minutes of like weird
nature documentary announcements and
stuff like that we won't go live until
the good stuff starts now so be on your
be on your couch yeah i am we might be
god we're halfway almost too goddamn
don't quit giving money everybody we we
love you uh but literally we don't want
to get to 600 bucks today both tommy and
i will be physically uh well 700 first
lady in the tramps 700
okay well they do get to 600 i wouldn't
mind saying
but one panel we got today we don't have
to wait till tomorrow four was they did
a big uh gaming panel uh where they
announced all kinds of games with disney
uh lucasfilm all this kind of stuff but
we got some interesting announcements
about marvel yeah games including like
kind of the one that was the most
exciting to us because we hadn't heard
anything about this this is a very
different kind of thing um they
announced a new
uh
game that will be featuring captain
america and black panther set during
world war two so it's not a t'challa or
a tachaka black panther but a character
named azuri who was t'challa's
grandfather so t'chaka's father who
would have been black panther during the
40s
if he was one of those faces we saw on
the ancestral plane someone could
probably point him out yeah one of the
panthers in the tree yeah yeah yeah yeah
and it's gonna be um so it's gonna be
steve rogers who's still the same steve
rogers because that guy is old as hell
yeah um azuri as black panther and then
you can also play as a uh uh
howling commando character or uh another
wakandan spy awesome right are the four
playable characters it looks really cool
it's like zoro
type of yes
but as a spy so i don't know what that
means i don't know if that means they're
in full regalia or hiding out or what
but uh looks really cool it's also from
amy hennig who has made a bunch of the
cool um uncharted uncharted games yes
yeah thank you um and so there's that
there's like a mobile ar style game that
somebody
uh
uh producer dodge was pointing out seems
like pokemon go but for marvel
superheroes which could either be
depending on your feelings the coolest
sounding thing you've heard about in a
long time or
lame uh 2014 news who knows um i bet
it'll be fun uh but and then we got this
is we've seen some stuff about this
before but a midnight suns game they saw
they did some more play footage of that
that's coming out later this year
um
and
update on uh
there's a lego star wars skywalker saga
game
coming out in about a month or november
first including it'll feature cassian
andor uh riva captain rex and more and
then um
uh brandon barrack's uh favorite little
thing atron
we have to get tron news tomorrow right
tron news it was on the poster well we
gotta get trump gotta get it well i mean
[Music]
speaking of disney's d23 convention it's
underway right now we've got you some
news the pixar uh and and disney
animated films panel is happening it
just kicked off five minutes ago uh
they're supposed to be announcing inside
out too which yeah
have you seen john checking his phone
he's just refreshing what was the drama
for inside out too so i guess mindy
kaling and uh bill hader are not coming
back for inside out this is oh this is
reporting that like i don't know if we
were able to source well but they're not
gonna work for the the
uh
the film because reportedly uh
amy player was was uh
be is being paid like five million
dollars to come back for for her her
voice acting they offered a hundred
thousand dollars
and they just walked they were like we
don't want to do this
a hundred thousand bucks whoa brandon in
the chats and melt these boys
get out of here brandon get out of here
nothing makes my mouth melt like you all
right but we've been doing d23 tomorrow
corn dogs
i'm talking to my friend brandon hey you
two aren't even in a mug competition and
that's what's potentially between you we
have the same mug um but
we've been talking about we've been
talking about marvel at d23 a lot and we
thought it would be only right to sort
of talk about you know there's two other
uh studios presenting at that panel 20th
century and lucasfilm so i just want to
kind of run through what we can expect
from both of those studios uh we're
going to talk more about 20th century in
a minute but um first things first we're
probably going to get something more
from avatar 2 yeah probably another
trailer
maybe something more substantial there
um
and then in terms of other 20th century
releases there's not a ton of heavy
hitters so you know they have that whole
like death on the niles uh
they had prey this year that was them
yeah maybe they'll announce some sequels
to some films in their catalog that
would be very cool again we're going to
talk about that a little bit more in a
bit but one of the things that brandon
and i were talking about earlier today
which i i kind of love is you know all
those fox x-men movies were under the uh
were under the banner of 20th century
and you know one of the most sort of
like fun his pitch for this was like a
very deadly kind of like heist film of
deadpool trying to go from the dead fox
x-men universe and like heist his way
into the marvel studios world i was like
what a fun way to like both marry these
you could see it being like a little bit
of a never-ending story kind of thing
the world is slowly melting away as he
races to get to the good ship feige or
whatever right as long as it ends with
idris elba
uh welcoming him to the dead sea uh the
mcu the way he welcomes natalie
appointment of valhalla
he finally breaks through and it's all
white like at marvel studios and he's
like welcome to the ncaa yeah
but these people be like what the [ __ ]
is he just hands him a brief case of
cash
but you know it's really interesting
because disney obviously bought
uh fox primarily for their catalog and
for the x-men um
there's no there's no saying that like
the x-men won't still be under that
banner right in the fantastic four yeah
of course but also lucasfilm
traditionally distributed their films
through uh
fox 20th century so i'd be curious to
see if uh i mean just for nostalgic
purposes alone i would love to get that
fox banner back on some of the star wars
films and i think we could see you know
who i mean wishful thinking like a
re-release of some old fox properties
yeah
maybe some old star wars cuts
there's a lot of
great franchises that 20th century fox
has had over the years right obviously
with predator and alien uh the die hard
franchise right famously filmed the
nakatomi plaza was actually the fox
studio building
in century city um there's some great
and like we're gonna talk about some
other like kind of one-off films that
are classics they might they could get
rebooted and different things like that
yeah but moving on to lucasfilm really
quickly right we could see footage or
trailers or or what have you obviously
andor is gonna be probably a big
presence there but uh both the
mandalorian season three three that you
got to see footage of that at
celebration uh um by all reports an
incredible seasonal reel i assume we're
going to get some of that online it
looks really good yeah um but also
ahsoka just got some casting news yeah
uh we've been hearing casting news all
week for the day interesting to have the
casting news come out a day before the
lucasfilm panel well you know it was it
was reported by the hollywood reporter
maybe they got a scoop and kind of sure
maybe the agents wanted to get the word
out yeah i wouldn't be surprised to see
rosario dawson and the person cast as
ezra sort of at the panel but um what
i'm most excited about is the skeleton
crew yeah that john watts is working on
is that what it is yeah
and i would love to see they might not
be shooting for they might not be
shooting that yet but like a concept art
sizzle reel sometimes they love to do
those kinds of things some voiceover
like we sort of got did we get like at
celebration or at the d23 a few years
ago that for andor yeah just like
overseas
diego luna kind of talking direct to
camera kind of a thing yeah so good so
that's sort of what we can expect from
the lucasfilm uh portion of that event i
don't think there's i i disagree oh ooh
i think come through i think we're going
to get tyka coming out on stage and
dropping
dropping the name and title card of his
movie i would love that i think we're
going to get a feature film announcement
tomorrow it's my prediction well you
know one of the biggest question marks
in film right now is what's the next
star wars movie yeah right right there's
a bunch in development talked about
directors that have been announced none
of them
uh the rogue squadron is that still
exists it's like
and you know what i wouldn't be
surprised if they announced
a new trilogy yeah right yeah oh the
trilogy
well especially like the the vibe in
hollywood right now if you listen to
kind of like industry experts and a lot
of these studio chiefs are saying this
including you know famously part of this
whole warner brothers hbo max uh
s show right is that like actually
we might have done too much on streaming
it might be time to push a little bit
more back into the theater as well yeah
like top gun maverick made a ton of
money spider-man no way it seems like
people are willing to go back to
theaters
if the movies are there right right
yeah grew so high and so fast that
they're i mean i mean it was like
those three movies probably saved brick
and mortar theaters absolutely
and they say that like hey giving these
people this stuff for 9.99 a month or
whatever
that's okay why don't we get 26 bucks
and concessions out of them right right
and what marvel is doing which is really
smart is or or i guess what disney is
doing which is smart is oh god i'm
watching i'm watching she-hulk and it's
just oh robert mueller
your report was unsatisfying and the
super cat is also
oh no
wow
okay we're starting to pour in we're
getting dangerously close to one chip
challenge
on all of you
what they're doing is right they're
feeding people with the shows to go get
them back into the theater right and and
with star wars in particular right
i mean a lot of fans were left
unsatisfied with the with the sequel
trilogy but but they still made a ton of
money
but like their their franchise is
they're keeping their franchise alive
with with the stuff on uh on tc plus
another fox thing that we didn't talk
about is uh
uh
indy 5. yes oh that's right
look at that you know i'm surprised my
good friend and frequent collaborator
harrison ford hasn't filled me in on
that no really i didn't know you were we
need to keep that asset on speed dial so
you can pull up tommy in here
but of course the main event for us and
for what i assume will be the panel is
the marvel stuff we've talked about that
at length uh if you want we we put out a
video last week where we went into depth
about what we expect but we've learned a
little bit more since then which is to
say holy reporter yesterday was
basically like yeah we're going to get
cash announcements we're going to get
release it dave we're going to get yeah
so at the very least i think what we can
expect is abraham's shame what he can
expect is a cast announcement for
fantastic four yeah it's been teased
like hell and
and uh and a secret invasion trailer
yeah i think that's that's
even that classic give us three seconds
of loki in a jumpsuit right
because i wouldn't be surprised give us
samuel jackson saying i'm getting too
old for this [ __ ] or something like that
right that's all we need yeah i wouldn't
i wouldn't be surprised too if we got
casting announcements for other projects
danny mcbride cast this reed richards i
was gonna say i think fantastic four is
gonna stop donating 20 increments to
psychopaths just one dollar buy a mug
yeah uh uh this is really gonna go
downhill real quickly as we quickly
approach um but we asked for your guys's
super chats uh let's uh let's read out a
couple of folks had some good you guys
had your wildest d23 takes i want to
read some of them right now uh uh seo
panther says hugh jackman to announce
the x-men cast wouldn't that be fun
like passing and then he was and then or
he was like and oh there's turning
here's logan
no some old [ __ ] name he jackman what
no no
first time super chat looking forward to
d23 news us two lauren uh you capri to
uh frequent uh a member of the super
chat thank you sir uh person uh morbid
time better than mandatory fun
my main lives for what pissing it that's
right get out of here
oh there's some other good uh a lot of
people backing up film juice for some
reason clearly mental illness is
contagious i gotta be honest zach and i
don't see eye to eye a lot but the one
thing we are in lockstep is film juice
needs to leave film juice you are a
menace
you are a distraction and i got
something to tell you this week the
juice is going to be squeezed
irving d with another wild d23
prediction i think they should make
alien and predator cannon to the mcu is
there a comics crossover there's god
there is i do have an alien comic book
yeah well and then predator
comics was a bit a staple for a long
time and dark horse and i think marvel
has since bought the rights right
i don't know boy that would mess up
these places apart
and they made the movies the alien vs
predator movies canon not just the
characters those movies
glad to be king has a has a good uh
point here marvel just released red hulk
as a featured character on one of their
games red hulk confirmed i mean we were
speculating about it a little bit
yesterday was she-hulk kind of expanding
the hulk world and uh corey don't back
up film juice nobody back cory you're a
friend of the show we care cory we care
about you this is pipe piper territory
where he's he's f he's leading you right
into the ocean okay
don't follow him don't follow him you're
gonna end up in a pile of broken morbid
time mugs if you follow film jesus
uh
uh yeah hugh jackman to announce x-men
cash that's a great i love that that's a
terrific i did see someone else uh this
is or sorry i was just interrupted to
say or patrick stewart yeah i know
we know he's in good grace
a little fun makeup in his head he's
like bleeding out of his eyes or
something or multiverse
kelsey grammer oh
beast noted mandatory finding fan
yeah kelsey grammer and i agree on
everything don't google it
don't google kelsey grammar right oh my
god pro-life t-shirt
another information in there that said
uh it said like um
uh denzel as uh professor x oh yeah like
that
and uh and john carlos esposito as uh
vice versa even the other way around i
like it um
darth zino19k i said what announcement
would make you just as hyped
uh for avengers five and six and
fantastic four keep up the great work
much love for montana hey check out uh
last best comedy in bozeman dartino if
you live anywhere near there um
yeah what would make it okay so
obviously we're all gonna be super hyped
for any fantastic four casting
announcement right there's been rumors
leaks lots of fan casting for years at
this point krazynski obviously
has entered the chat uh we don't know
that he's going to be confirmed there um
and and like avengers five and six is
tough because like we have no idea who's
going to be in the avengers by the time
we get to those films and i don't know
that you can even announce that yet
right i mean unless they unless they
introduce the x-men i think that would
be if they introduce the x-men in any
way shape or form everyone's gonna
everyone's gonna want them to be in
those movies and i think that would blow
that blow my mind yeah
you know uh i know the russo brothers
haven't been making hits lately but if
they announce the russo brothers to be
directing secret wars that's going to
blow the roof off yeah convention center
i mean gray man was a hit wasn't it i
don't know no i don't know well not
critically well they came out and like
said like theaters don't matter uh
netflix is where we want to be
yeah and this is like some behind the
scenes mumbo jumbo but they're they're
doing a show at amazon that's supposedly
a big
a big cluster f um it was uh connor
lauren wagner that said denzel as
magnetic
uh he said gus from bb which is
giancarlo esposito as professor x ooh
i mean
we're too close to this
we're too close everybody
you got almost 10 minutes listen
i want you to think about
your little trash children tonight and
how they want to eat their canned peas
and uh banana peels that you find
don't spend any more money on us i'm a
very famous internet personality okay
i'm gonna go home and eat steak and
lobster tonight with a mouth as cool as
a cucumber
because while your trash bags have risen
up on your glad tidy bags to a height
you never dreamed possible you'll never
sit as high as the king the king sits on
a throne of the throne of gold and he
shits in a toilet bowl of gold wow he
actually says any updates on the mug
count
yeah john i i i hate this for you
what 88
which is pretty good morgan time bugs
wow 102. oh
102 dalmatians
i'm getting
disgustingly close
the end of the show is going to be
lethal yes for everyone but again just a
quick recap
oh no
oh
we're at 6 30. we are a perilous 67. 62.
we could be late tommy and i
about eight minutes left in this show
we got a whole we got a whole another
block we got
john's filling in the mud challenge
behind us wow we are getting and john is
perilously close to having to
eat a mug full of absolute
garbage
you know what
we've talked about a lot of fun things
today but
we also discussed the fact that last
night i went to battle yeah i went to
battle and i did serious damage to my
liver my heart my lungs all the things
dr nasty has been putting the kings of
the jungle inside of me for months
has been destroyed
luckily
we have a partner here that sponsors
oh my god anita oh
no
we'll get to you soon anita i needed you
to stop
because
she needed
i needed you i needed you to put that
money back can you take this guy can you
take a super chat back i do yeah
thoughts that i know you don't need to
type that in i get it
at least first time
long time viewer been waiting for
something epic to drop some cash love
zaddy but got my mandatory fun mug today
i have to thank geology
and is a fresh face friday and my face
is about to be a lot less fresh however
they did help me pull together a little
bit today let's thank geology for
sponsoring the break room uh this week's
fresh face is mine and that's right as
you know tomorrow hopefully i'll be
going down to d23 i may be in the
emergency room it's my first d23 so i
want my face to be nice and fresh eric's
already down there but he was born
gorgeous babyface voss brandon is going
to be there too but he's getting all his
hair lasered off today so he can be
aerodynamic for that hotel pool we're
going to be swimming in but what about
me big t
so that's why we thank geology my face
can be smooth healthy and hydrated they
offer a whole range of products to help
your skin look its best they'll even
find the products best suited to your
needs you can take a quick quiz at
geology.com new rockstars and they'll
suggest the perfect lineup of skin care
items for you head over to
geology.com you sick freaks
new rockstars here's our promo code
rockstar 70 to save 70 percent off
new rockstars
head over to geology.com new slash new
rockstars use our promo code
rockstars70 to save 70 off remember you
use that code it makes us look good to
the sponsors more sponsors means more
shows means more of these stupid chips
that you're going to make
oh no
we got cory can drilly hot take gin
carly esposito asthma fisco
i've opened the coffin-shaped box i
don't even you're not even supposed to
touch it really and then touch your eyes
or whatever 120. wait a hundred oh oh
you're doing it oh my god this is a mug
there's a mug thing dude
mandatory fun today i don't think we
have time i think this is the yeah
instead instead of mandatory fun it's
going to be mandatory pain as tommy and
i are going to
ladies
and gents again anytime we both commit
to something physically
like when you shaved your chest and then
i wore your hair on like
you can't help themselves dark this this
[ __ ] that is shiny pure
liquid lava
this was our idea
why did we even allow why are you still
donating money
stop donating
is more you need to venmo me
uh for my hospital bills no we'll put
their bodies to the test today we
already did the geology plug because my
face is about to turn by purple
[Laughter]
oh yeah there we go
that's a little too fast i guess
should've went a little no
oh my god there's so much powder okay
there's no water in my mouth oh my god
ah there's no water in my mouth oh that
was that was beyond worth it guys
they're off on the corner just to give
you a play-by-play they're screaming and
blood is pouring out of different
orifices tommy is chugging from the
waterfowl he's putting his mouth on the
water fountain you ever wondered if he
was that kind of a guy he is like
sandfield is gambit mannequin party i
love that
and we love seeing how much pain
these guys are in
zack walk us through what you're feeling
give us
we want to do like coyote peterson we
want to know what pain you're going
through exactly right now let us know
oh my god i can't even talk i think
my mouth is blue mommy you got to get
back in here
tommy is chugging gallons
of water fountain water tommy ended up
on the wrong end of it i think he got
about two-thirds of that chip
oh god
tommy is about to heave he's off on the
side head on the knees leaning over why
do we do this
that water fountain is officially
unusable folks i am not sugar coating he
is spinning up spitting out trying to do
everything he can to survive oh god
all of this
i was gonna say john's trying to do his
best to get an angle on him
uh so we'll sit tight on that but zach
are you hanging in there tune in
tomorrow here we go
um
we got some pumpkin munching happening
oh god tommy i heard mustard helps a lot
i heard mustard really helps with the
heat you want to try some of that okay
tomorrow for our live d23 coverage
tommy and brandon will be in anaheim
grab your bugs folks i'll be here in the
studio dying
uh we'll report on all the lucasfilm
marvel and 20th century
announcements
those are real tears folks
real
i blame you film juice
but also everybody else that donated
today anita shame on you john hayden
you're all awful no you guys are oh god
okay we gotta go we gotta go john we
gotta go
we got a clip of the week tommy throw
the clip of the week
go [ __ ] yourself not the face kneel and
beg for it
not the pain no
i agree with everything you said
but you killed my mother
oh god
oh no